I like those two but again those cut my
voice - I don't know what I'm doing
wrong yeah but um yeah I so would but
with alcohol I will say like I just
could see it snowballing into a point
where I would quit again but I just I've
never I'm miss drinking a lot for the
sex thing for the dancing thing like
just dancing to music in general like is
more fun if you drunk yeah just life
like first two drinks like life is
pretty great yeah drinks yeah good
sending text messages I don't want to
send reaching out to guys they don't
want to talk to in the morning all of
that anxiety and the hangover that's
what I'm avoiding is the hangover and
with weed you know I don't have a
hangover yeah do you get hangovers
yeah from weed no no sure and does it
make you want to quit and question
everything I mean how do you keep your
drink in check um I've never had a
problem with drinking and in like it's
never been like god I need a drink
I've never been like they like like
sober October was the first time I did
absolutely nothing for a whole month I
didn't smoke a joint I didn't do
mushrooms I didn't at nothing right
wasn't that hard what was interesting
about it was the dreams first of all
because the dreams come hard and fast
when you're off the weed and they
because apparently I talked to this guy
dr. Matthew Walker who is a dream
specialist and he was on the podcast
discussing the importance of sleep sleep
specialist I should say but he was
saying that marijuana it impedes certain
aspects of REM sleep which is when you
do all your dreaming so when you um get
off the marijuana your brain apparently
makes up for lost time and hits you with
some crazy [ __ ] dream talking frogs
and [ __ ] unicorns and you know roller
coasters that go straight to heaven and
like [ __ ] bananas dreams did you have
that or you haven't my god well the
thing is this time for sober October I
was way tapered off by the time this
rolled around like I smoked a little pot
in Toronto on Saturday
I mean a little like I took like one or
two hits I had a drink maybe two drinks
I think I had one drink when I went on
stage and then I had a couple glasses of
wine after the show we went out to this
restaurant after the show but yeah it
was the eat this was an easy one because
I was kind of but I think I slowed down
after last year I think doing that sober
October thing made me realize like hmm
there's like some there's some of that
school that right unfortunately that all
my favorite comics did drugs all of them
yeah hex Kinnison Pryor everyone did
drugs they were they were all I mean
Pryor was coke I've never touched coke
but Kennison was coke - but Hicks was
more psychedelics and I mean he did coke
and alcohol and all other stuff before
but there was there was oh they were all
like these wild [ __ ] like Ron White is
a good friend of mine always drunk and
there's like this part of that life that
you know this so it's so attractive
because it's just like this wild loose
carefree rebellious figured out tomorrow
life and that's that's the life of the
comic but I realized like after last
year sober October that there's a lot of
stuff you could do if you're sober like
and it's I think as I said you can abuse
alcohol but you can also use it you know
you can use it you can you can have a
couple drinks and feel good and you
enjoy the moment more you know there's
there's something there's something to
it but it's really a matter of your own
personality and discipline it's like how
much and how much of an addict are you
like what how much what is it
what holes are missing in your brain
that get filled up with that booze and
that like once you take the booze away
there's like this gaping chasm that you
need to fill you know what is that and
you got to figure out who you are
because I know some people that can't
have anything they have one drink and
then they're off to the races and
they're doing math yeah